[Music]
you know what there's nothing better the
being of Ko dad you got that right daddy
two families working as one cohesive
unit we got a big surprise no more back
and forth the Christians not do in the
back of note I just said that
but together Christmas like a normal
family yeah they're Christmas hello
grandpa Kurt
my dad's gonna stop at everything we do
nothing's ever good enough and your
father hasn't met the new evolved dusty
we who wouldn't be impressed with you
man dear God it's gonna come off we're
dusty but he's beautiful
there you go why don't you bring the car
around we'll meet you at the curb right
away sir I mean no I'm sorry I'm not the
driver no I'm Brad just stepped out and
why is he here because my dad's coming
to these total lack of masculinity I
mean he's weak chin and soft underbelly
bothers you not a bit you know I'm just
getting a feeling maybe you guys would
like some privacy I just want to find
the perfect together Christmas trick you
don't think I can operate a chainsaw
[Music]
[Applause]
this is getting good boys
ready and white game
[Music]
[Music]